the emperor asks us to bring peace
to arrakis
there is no call we do not answer there
is no faith that we betray
house atreides accepts
i dream about june for a very long time
since day one the old project has been
designed to be seen on the imax screen
denny is a bit obsessed with this so who
better to direct him
i've been having dreams about arrakis
his imagery creates a beautiful intense
experience then you get sucked into it
the whole thing feels like the
dreamscape on a massive scale the desert
takes the weak
now our traitors will live
this film is larger than anything that
i've ever
done it's the genius of frank herbert on
a huge scale
we spoke a lot about the feel and the
emotion and how big the film is it's
beyond big
i want to create an immersive experience
and the imax will be used for the impact
of the desert under human soul
it was imax that gave us that size that
scale that scope that we were after
i hope the audience will be blown away i
want them to be excited i want them to
be moved trust me that you're going to
return
that's what you want in a movie with me
[Music]
you